welcome to this video playing Nino DG
never played him from argentina
argentine yet Fleck we have okay
sticking with my tried and trusted
double kick pod but what line am I going
to play us soon they still don't know
okay is playing this line 6 and 6 d 3
it's mostly an end time Marshall I mean
the Marshall players they'd certainly
yeah i mean i know they maybe have an
issue with this move but if you play
closed and Ruiz anyway you don't mind
this so much I'm just playing the kind
of normal stuff that you always do here
re-routing this to g7 it's just a
slowish version of the clothes gray with
age three and so on don't them don't
really fear that in any way not that is
not that I'm better anything it's just
that if you are used to the closed room
you don't mind this position it's just
almost the same thing if you play the
marshal however your kind of used to far
more concrete play more like attacking
play and open positions and then this is
definitely something different okay so
I'm going to play Knight a5 and try for
see five year depending on his reply
okay is giving me this temple don't see
why not now see five mm-hmm okay I mean
to see no thinking it can maybe take and
try to use the c5 pawn like a Tekkit we
should be three or so between 67 lat c4
is good nothing happening yeah like that
this looks decent I managed to
fianchetto in some cases I might be just
able to
to open the center and use my bishop on
g7 you can also go d 5 which is leading
20 this is an entirely different idea
huh okay yet submits a bit surprising I
well I think that actually something
like let's say um if he goes a three
let's start like that he doesn't oh it
just takes okay well that cannot be that
dangerous really I wonder ever should
take how should I take actually not at
the pawn he has to I think spend a move
on the cover of the beef up on in like
Bishop is sick that looks kind of normal
the bishop would like to be on evade
though I wonder ever should just play a
five really just quickly opening it yeah
why not I'm a little bit better
developed at the this precise moment a
little bit quicker take here
Bishop f8 system I don't know now maybe
check before he was not exactly very
quick with this moose so for once I'm
not behind on the clock okay maybe a
queen is not doing anything on d 8 yeah
this is suddenly and equal ish this
position I think what now yeah didn't
think of this move so much but it's not
bad of course screen be too was a good
move so is ticking there yeah and Bishop
t6 is not to have not a happy move and
but anyway what can I do okay that I
have to treat and I don't have much
choice them
and yeah I was just thinking hmm can you
take that hmm I guess he can
yeah it just but put annoying yeah but
should be 525 but should be three Queen
f6 hmm
I also cannot take ear for unfortunately
hmm i don't have a good move here cannot
take on e4 or whatever it's not working
so if i take here yeah moving the night
is also not very exciting actually I
don't know ha what a shame I really like
my position I was thinking I was ok but
it must have miss plated not quite sure
whether what the problem was ok I don't
mind the Queen trade the before the
before porn is quite weak so queer look
takes her bouquet 7a for this kind of
thing his bishop is at the moment not so
great ok he's avoiding that I don't want
to treat this as well yeah I couldn't
take on before he ate was hanging was
chick maybe can I am can take and play
maybe Quincy five this kind of more oh
he's giving you the pawn why ok
I take it absolutely check time morning
b5 494 maybe yeah I still should push
this key is can you can give me this
check it's okay other twin c8
ok
30 seconds check check
yeah I cannot calculate anymore here
this is a problem check it's not not the
did not expect let's see check just give
us a ton of chicks check check check
check check check check yeah I could
just about save this with no time on the
clock we okay yeah I was I was I don't
know hey i don't know i mean the the
past pawn is certainly good but the
night the night queen combination is
this is awkward really awkward to play
against so what is better Quincy five or
queen t-6s yeah once you see the movie
it's quite quickly I have to prevent e5
and prepare this a little bit and then
I'm really better yeah I was surprised
that he gave me the before porn there
was really no reason to do so I was
thinking that I mean I can debate about
many things but I think here check isn't
this kind of okay for widened its upon
the comps s equal due to age 5 age for
he did see that one and avoided it hmm
maybe I
no yeah I mean we had a about equal
position here and it was some it was a
surprising move net c4 also possible i
was thinking i would attack d find be
for now 85 around here thought there
should be quite okay nothing special but
about equal but all of a sudden I got
into this this weird situation here the
engine recommends this move k stakes
here and this yeah okay I see them as he
the idea but you know I've got the
bishop pair for porn and some
compensation after this you just wants
to play this it's that it just wants the
players yeah it's very computer issue so
i was just doing doing this and hoping
that i have some civ ish some play
against the spawn and that this night is
not so great down it here mum I'm better
but I really have to play Queen and
queen to d6 Queen to see five of those
kind of moves ok Wow tense game thanks
for watching